[Applause]
ann hash remains in extreme critical
condition following a life-threatening
car crash last friday and now source
tells e.t her 20-year-old son homer is
taking the lead in making sure she's
getting the best care
i decided i'm going to be the best mom
oh that was a cue
i know you you are you oh et's watched
homer grow up and now it seems he's
acting as ant's protector advocating for
her care as she remains in a coma our
source says he's being as strong as he
can be adding that anne's loved ones are
all hoping for a recovery and has
sustained life-threatening injuries
these are the most serious injuries that
we see
in burn care her family is on pins and
needles just praying her family is ready
to surround her be there if she wakes up
everyone is waiting for that to happen
they're gonna remove the body from the
vehicle and probably transport the
victim to a hospital it took nearly 60
firefighters to rescue anne from that
wreckage last friday following the fiery
crash the actress's rep told et she's on
a ventilator and her burns require
surgical intervention she was in an
enclosed space the car as well as an
apartment so that allowed smoke as well
as toxic gases to build up with a high
concentration which attacked her airway
and prevented her from breathing so
she's most likely in a medically induced
coma
meaning that she's on heavy sedation
and she also has severe pain
from her burn injuries and while anne
remains hospitalized the lapd is
investigating her for misdemeanor dui
and hit and run they're looking into
what role drugs or alcohol may have
played in the collision
[Music]
following the crash attention focused on
ann claiming to have been drinking vodka
and wine on the better together podcast
that day but sometimes days just suck
and i don't know if you ever have them
but you know some days mama says i'm
just going to be like this some days
there's those no good very bad days it's
just [ __ ] me up so i'm drinking some
vodka and wine but there was confusion
the show's producer tells e.t that it
was actually recorded earlier that week
days before the accident and turns out
anne's loved ones aren't happy about
those headlines our source says her
friends and family are absolutely
devastated and heartbroken since anne's
in a coma fighting for her life she has
no voice here it has been difficult for
them to read salacious headlines reports
about anne they feel as though her
character is being attacked they are
trying to focus on getting anne better
and it's very hard when they have these
negative distractions
[Music]